wow wow
that looks so good
Ethan Ethan you look amazing
oh my God Ethan you look amazing Oliver
who wears this I wouldn't if I wouldn't
if I were you we'll change back after
but how you guys feeling I feel like I'm
in the middle I feel horrible so you
feel pretty cool this is the world
Oliver it seems like that I do feel kind
of cool I feel like a combination of the
Matrix and that one old lady who makes
the costumes and the incredible wow oh
and that's not even right hey look at me
look at me wow see now we're starting to
get somewhere okay don't hit Oliver all
of us hey you messed up
there I'm not gonna get physical with
you today hey Oliver Oliver over here
I'm trying to help Oliver over here over
here over here